what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Brad Michaelson is the
u.s. senior marketing manager at eToro
in this conversation we discussed the
current state of marketing and crypto
how people should be thinking about
customer acquisition what the inherent
challenges on certain marketing
platforms are and what is coming up next
for eToro I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto com that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother-in mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
comm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box if you plug it in
connect to your Wi-Fi five minutes or
less you're mining Bitcoin all you have
to do is control it from the mobile app
they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block by
and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out black Viacom / pump again
that's block 5 com / pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today Anthony pomp
lion-o is a partner at Morgan Creek
Digital all pinnings expressed by pump
or his guests on this podcast are solely
their opinions and do not reflect the
opinions of Morgan Creek digital or
Morgan Creek Capital Management you
should not treat any opinion expressed
by pomp as a specific inducement to make
a particular investment or follow a
particular strategy but only as an
expression of his opinion this podcast
is for informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Brad
here he's sitting in the hot seat he's
not leaving until tells us all the
marketing secrets thanks so much for
coming in and doing this thanks for
having me Paul what's your background
where'd you get started how the hell do
you end up at eToro doing marketing well
I actually started as a journalist way
back in the day when I was 15
started a blog was mostly a music
journalist so I would shoot bands and
film concerts and you know there was
sort of my first exposure to what I
didn't even consider is marketing at the
time as you know posting links on music
forums getting traffic ended up getting
the point where it was like almost
scalable I ended up going to college I
was an editor college paper but after
college ended up pivoting into PR so I
had a little shop for a bit where'd you
go to college I grew up in Canada so I
went to the University of Victoria on
the west coast got it
and then what was PR what were you doing
there I was doing music PR as well so by
the end of it we had about a dozen
clients Western Canadian acts that were
touring the country touring the US and
then you know a year and a bit into that
I ended up going to New York for a
summer and then never leaving what
brought you to New York mostly for work
so
at the time I thought that I'd be able
to pivot from Canadian PR into US PR and
who would have guessed it's not as easy
as you would expect coming to you know a
different coast in a different City
making new contacts that sort of thing I
ended up pivoting into copywriting and
then ended up going over to my first
agency I worked at I was at a digital
agency started as an account manager and
ended up climbing the ladder to director
of strategy at the agency we're mostly
ecommerce clients we specialized in post
8 funding
startups and scaling those brands out
some of those brands now are on the New
York City subways which is quite a
thrill to see and I was really exciting
and from there I moved in house and and
after that made my first professional
move into crypto what's the first time
you ever heard about crypto first time I
heard about crypto was in 2012 when I
was sort of just discovering reddit in
college I started reading on I can't
even remember which subreddits people
were talking about Bitcoin buying stuff
with Bitcoin but at the exact same time
actually my little cousin I found out
had been mining for like a year at that
point but yeah it's crazy and you know
he sort of sold me on the philosophy of
Bitcoin sold me on the you know the the
technicals of crypto in general and why
permissionless transfers of value are so
valuable and I've sort of just been
growing that as a hobby for a long time
I about a year after that I found out
there's about a dozen of my friends back
home we were all closeted Bitcoin people
so we started a slack group and I'm
still in that today we talk about market
sentiment news and share each other's
experience some of us are full time
crypto now so it's really fun it's
awesome what oh what really good caught
your eye in the beginning when you saw
it because it's so different and I'm
coming from music what was the
the big catch there I think the first
thing for me was like I sort of alluded
to before as permissionless transfers of
value so the first use case that really
stuck with me and honestly still is what
I think about the most is remittance
payments cross-border payments being
able to transfer value from one country
to another for pennies almost instantly
and what really sold me on this is I've
got a friend back home Josef Weinberg
works on shift Network I know he's been
on the show before and that was one of
his first projects was a remittance
project and ever since then it's sort of
always stuck with me you guys knew each
other before crypto we grew up together
really yeah Wow alright so when you
decide hey descriptive things real you
know bitcoins interesting etc what was a
kind of how did you get to eat or what
was the path Wow yeah so I started my
first crypto company I guess three years
ago they were post ICO and I helped them
launch their platform which was really
fun we also launched a conference that
still goes on to this day during New
York blockchain week after that I
actually moved on to block Phi where I
was the director marketing and was there
for a bit and that was really fun and
really formative for me Zechs
an amazing person to work for and you
know he really gives you the opportunity
to experiment and and you know he gave
me the opportunity to grow that brand
and now they are what they are and that
was a really fantastic experience what
was was the best part about block Phi
and before I view all the trolls on
Twitter get mad I'm an investor in block
5 through Morgan Creek their advertisers
on the podcast is all the disclosures
but they're awesome go sign up for an
account
block by comm slash Punk
it works it doesn't work right
actually Brad is the one who the very
first ad we ever ran on it's rod cast
lesser as a brighter block fine yeah
sorry what was that question what can
just keep saying Viacom / pawn that's
right
but what kind of caught your attention
about going to work at block 5 was it
the team the product just you want to do
like gold more full time into crypto
yeah will really convinced you that's a
great question I mean I do I only do
great questions on the podcast at that
point you know I was two feet into
wanting to take on crypto as a career
like I'm not a trader so that's not
really my angle I focus on customer
acquisition and growing brands right so
what I saw
with block fie was that here's a company
that's gotten some funding from an
except for a few exciting places and
this was still when we were on our seed
they're not an ICO company which was
something that I personally wanted to
avoid going forward and their product
was something that I saw immediate use
cases for at the time you know salt was
still a relatively big name and there
are other major players in the space as
well so that was the original draw and
then you know once I started talking to
Zack about his vision for the long-term
there's a lot of really cool things they
have in their pipeline obviously we
launched the block by interest account
last year which has been really exciting
and that's still growing rapidly I use
it myself
you guys should probably go use it as
well I use it to that not no financial
advice but I use it exactly so yeah that
was a really cool experience for me and
a lot of you know best practices setting
there and yeah got it and then you moved
over to eToro earlier this year
what uh what was that like that was a
really cool experience so you know after
speaking with yoni our CEO and speaking
with guy who's our MD of the US business
that was sold pretty quickly on the
company you know we we've been around
for 12 years we have 11 million users on
the platform if you go to London right
now you toros on all the cabs we want we
sponsor six Premier League teams so it
was a little bit of stepping into a
pedigree which was really cool but on
top of that you know eToro has obvious
differentiators in the market the the
social trading features the copy
features I just saw a really big
opportunity in that and you know it's
it's like working in a start-up startup
environment because there's like 20
people in our office but we have the
infrastructure of a you know very large
organisation what what does eToro do I
think a lot of people start with what
exactly does eToro do alright so eToro
is a social trading platform what is
that
these are some [ __ ] yo yeah so by
the way disclosure we are investors in
the Torah that Morgan Creek go ahead so
to put it most basically we have a
number of features on the platform that
are it's more than just your normal spot
by cell right so the most basic part of
the social features are that every asset
on the platform has a social feed
globally we have over 2,000 assets in
the US where crypto only right now with
equity is coming next year so you click
on Bitcoin you see the social feed
people are posting market sentiment
they're posting charts we've pretty
advanced charting features on the site
you know competes with what trading view
does for example but on top of that you
can click on people's profiles you can
see their entire portfolio broken down
by percentages as well as their cost
basis over time which is really exciting
and actually so this is like Twitter
where people are like oh I'm so smart
look at my ta you can click on their
profile and be like you're down 40% I
would just you know maybe not show the
charts and worry about making money and
said yeah that's right so that's a
really big part of it and we've got
these copy
teachers which are really exciting so a
couple weeks ago we launched this new
copy portfolio through a partnership
with a company called the tie that I
think a bunch of people probably saw on
Twitter what the tie does is they have
access through a third party to the
actual firehose of Twitter mm-hmm so
they ingest like eight hundred and fifty
million tweets a day from crypto Twitter
that cut out the spam they score the
tweets and they basically produce
signals for prop traders and they
generate their yield off their trading
strategies so what we did with them is
we partnered made a light version of
their signal strategy and we launched
that publicly for Atari users around the
world got it and how does the copy
trader functionality work right so copy
trader is sort of a parallel feature
that actually allows you to copy all the
trades of other traders and that happens
automatically on your account at the
exact same price that they execute at in
real time that is probably our most
popular feature globally and that's
actually launching in the US on October
29th got it and so really this is if you
have an account and I think that you're
smart I want to follow you I can say hey
just copy what Brad does if you own if
you're in Europe and you own Apple stock
and you sell your Apple stock then it
would sell it in my portfolio as well
if you then took that money and you
bought some other was a Bitcoin then it
would buy Bitcoin in my account as well
it's just literally mimics exactly what
you're doing in real time so I get
basically the performance that you get
and so rather than give you my money to
manage I'm basically just copying what
you're doing that's right that's exactly
how it works with the global product for
example you mentioned stocks so in the
US where crypto only right now but you
know once we launch on the 29th we'll
have between 50 and 60 traders available
to be copied on the platform the people
who are what listed to be copied those
people actually get rewarded for being
copied
which is really exciting and like you
said the people copying copying them get
the benefit
of the strategy the trading strategy of
the person they're copying all right
so before I forget you can go to the
website eToro dot-com slash pop and
there's a whole bunch of stuff here
around trading etc what's your role at
eToro right so I run US marketing for
each arm what does that mean so customer
acquisition brand marketing I oversee
event marketing as well as PR anything
that's sort of outward facing from a
messaging or acquisition standpoint all
right and as you guys look at the US
market today because you're equipped to
only like what are the channels that
you're the most active on yeah so that's
that's a really good question so on a
social side of things were really at we
try to be really active on crypto
Twitter right you know that's sort of
the holy grail that's where we all spend
most of our time so we're developing you
know maturing a program to spread the
word for you to Touro on there you know
at the same time we like to leverage
influencer relationships so today you
might have seen a tweet go out from Ben
Askren who we've partnered with which is
really exciting earlier this year you
might have seen that we partnered with
Bitcoin is which was founded by Russell
o Kong and the Chargers so that's really
exciting and there's some more cool
partnerships coming out soon from o to
tell us about any of them right now no I
don't think I can do that hey all right
just just thought I could get you good
on top of that you might have been
hearing about eToro through a number of
podcasts that we sponsor including yours
you know it's a big channel for a lot of
people in crypto it's been really
effective for me at other companies I've
worked with and it's you know a direct
line to our lowest funnel customer
mm-hmm absolutely
so socials big podcasts are big anything
else that you guys have that you're
active with yes so we also advertise on
the social platforms where we can we buy
ad space on
others that you know we think our
customers are on you know we don't
really buy articles we buy banners I
know that there's a there's some
confusion with that sometimes and in
crypto land so we like to experiment a
little bit with everything but we when
we try something we do a real deep dive
execution on those plants cool so I
wanted to bring you in because I want to
talk about just marketing in general but
specifically around crypto as well right
um let's go through the different
channels and just kind of give me your
philosophy right or the framer thing you
use to experience some of this so social
and Twitter specifically like how do you
think about what the value prop is like
what's the best way to actually engage
there what do you see being effective or
not effective yeah that's a great
question so all the third time you said
that it must be really great
you're a pro man so it really depends on
the product right tell Peter McCormick
that go ahead so it really depends on
the product right so we are a trading
platform obviously you know there's the
the the key value propositions being
social trading platform great place to
buy and sell the basics right good app
the whole deal but then you have to
think about who your customer is where
they are what are the most effective
ways to access these people and develop
your full marketing funnel right so you
have your upper funnel where you're just
trying to get fresh eyeballs we're
trying to get people into the brand
following along in one way or another
these are typically through social media
working through affiliates banner ads
sponsoring newsletters that sort of
thing and then you've got your medium
funnel where you're engaging with you
know your customers directly who reach
out to you on social media on the
platform itself you're leveraging them
to
promote your brand further through
things like refer-a-friend programs
you're hitting them through email
marketing there's a million different
things to hit on this funnel and then
you've got sort of your lower funnel
where you're worried about conversion so
we like to we're investing quite a bit
in optimizing our website funnel our
customer acquisition funnel and just
making it as smooth as possible for
people during the onboarding process got
it top of the funnel what have you guys
tried that hasn't worked or even if it's
not an e Toro specific thing just like
what are things that you think might be
a misconception in marketing that you're
like oh that seems to be a top of funnel
thing but there's actually not nearly as
effective as people think hmm I think
that posting memes on crypto Twitter are
not as effective as some people think
why Twitter is so fleeting of a platform
that that although sometimes you're
winning a little bit of mine share
you're not actually selling people that
selling is not the right word but you're
not endearing you're themselves to your
brand so sometimes that's a liability
but none of these things are like xyd
existential truths right sometimes
things don't work some things do work
sometimes an ad campaign that you put
all over the subways and train stations
whatever doesn't work in the immediate
term but it's an investment for a
long-term strategy that will actually
pay off ten months later yeah so I don't
know if there's one specific thing
that's straight up doesn't work it's all
contextual and it's all timely you know
yeah and and do you feel like you can
try to script like the customer journey
where you're like hey we know we need a
hit customer six or seven times with
different messages on different
platforms then they convert yeah are you
able to kind of in the marketing plans
maybe identify or measure at that level
of granularity or is it much more kind
of hey you know we ran banner ads on a
website this how many people saw how
many people clicked and then we could
which you can't really necessarily track
back how many other times they see your
ads and things like that like like what
level of granularity can you actually
get to yeah so I mean the objective is
always to get as granular as possible
even if your strategy doesn't go through
all those layers of granularity right so
yes you want to be as involved in
possible in your customer acquisition
funnel you know you have everything from
you have everything from retargeting
banners that start serving the day of or
the day after someone hits your website
you have you know drip campaigns coming
from email campaigns when someone
becomes a lead or becomes a funded
customer so for those things you want to
be as granular as possible because
there's a million opportunities to
optimize but sometimes you know there is
such thing as being too granular because
the program becomes too complex so in
order to a be test or optimize those
programs in a long-term it needs to be
like a manageable size right so if you
have an email drip campaign that's 25
steps deep that's way too many because
you're gonna be testing buttons and call
to actions and wording and graphics on
25 different emails simultaneously and
you need you know a full team of people
to do that sort of thing when you're
talking about the sort of campaigns that
you can be a little bit more high-level
on there's a lot of opportunities for
that stuff so when you're doing podcast
advertising for example these are
investments in a brand right
these aren't direct response activations
so you come up with some ad copy some
talking points you let those run for a
few weeks see how that performs change
it up for a few more weeks compare the
two it really depends on your marketing
style but there are certain things that
you can get out about and other things
you sort of just have to let it breathe
yeah and then how do you think about
when I worked at Facebook and we would
work on growth rings I think Chrome
users we burnt used to break it down
into there's new user acquisition
there's retention work they have turns
in this resurrection is that a general
framework that you guys look at or do
you have some twist on it in terms of
how you guys actually measure yeah
absolutely so we have acquisition teams
retention teams customer service teams
so they kind of hit different points in
that customer journey all the way
through got it but like you were
alluding to there's sort of the
acquisition retargeting and like
conversion channels even just in your
acquisition side of things and yeah you
have different priorities and and
messaging and funnels for all those
different steps yeah and the reason I
ask is because one of the things that's
different about crypto and Bitcoin then
let's say like you know yeah a social
application or a mobile app or something
is that like the whole idea like holding
is a use case yeah right so I went on
somewhere I bought Bitcoin and I'm just
holding on to it yeah I'm not
necessarily transacting I'm not
necessarily you know doing anything with
I'm not selling it or anything but
because I'm holding it I still am a user
right and so are you an active user are
you not an active user right that
changes the way that you think about
retention and resurrection of turn users
etc I just like how do you think of that
having come from like the not crypto
world yeah the crypto world and kind of
what's the comparison there yeah I mean
I consider myself one of those people
that you just described like I first
bought in 2013 and I have never sold any
of it like I'm just a long-term holder
so my lifetime value on an exchange is
the fact that I dollar-cost average so I
buy small amount once a week and I've
been doing that for a couple years and
that's my value to them however for
customers that sort of buy once a
quarter like once every few months those
are valuable people too because a lot of
these people keep their equity on the
exchange
so that's valuable to the company as
well there's opportunities to upsell
from a I guess in crypto upselling is
more like encouraging people to educate
themselves more in order to I don't know
improve their trading strategies if
they're that kind of investor or just in
general engage with your brand in a way
that they're enriching their knowledge
in the category for sure what um what
are some of the campaign's that you've
seen others run that you're impressed by
I think cos it is really amazing things
and I think that the core from a
marketing perspective with them is that
they obviously pay a lot of attention to
customer experience and you know this is
a brand that's not just online like so
much in crypto is medical internet money
that you have no physical connection to
and they do a really fantastic job of
making the complex process of you know
becoming your own [ __ ] something that's
user friendly but also aesthetically
nice and I you know I'm constantly
looking at what they're doing as sort of
a leading indicator for where we should
all be trying to go who else anybody
else I really like block by it's you
know I think that from a high level with
crypto let's say crypto adoption to the
point where we all sort of are striving
and hoping that we're all going to end
up where everyone in you know the USA is
engaged in one way or another with
either Bitcoin or cryptocurrency more
largely there's three steps how I think
about it so there's sort of like the MVP
which was you know early days people
sort of buying stuff a little bit of
something here a little bit something
there
Bitcoin wasn't really worth that much at
the time and there were fluctuations but
it wasn't something that we thought we
would be you know I didn't know we'd be
in a office in Midtown men
recording a podcast five years ago right
I got dress shoes on today too nice
looking sharp
go ahead so they're sort of like that
MVP stage next we've sort of got our our
you know we're thinking about it like
building a product right so you got your
beta testers and we've got a little bit
of a proof of concept so people are
onboarding into the ecosystem we're
seeing that the base layer is usable you
can trust it you know the Bitcoin
protocol hasn't been you know taken over
by some bad actor so we have a bit of an
idea of where we can go and we're sort
of listening to the needs of the
consumer and we're sort of in in some
middle stage before what the third one
is which is more of like a mass adoption
right like we have the whole stacking
SATs phenomenon which is kind of in my
mind a little bit of a placeholder for
whatever that next step is but where I
see block Phi's role is you know we
before we're building all this future
tech and there has to be context for
this future tech and I really think that
the first step to getting there is
building financial tools within the
crypto ecosystem that sort of mirror
what goes on in the traditional finance
world in order to get people comfortable
with the technology and then from there
you can start building and innovating to
whatever that future tech is because
people are already on boarded into this
decentralized free flow of money
technology and how do you think about
like what I'll call more of the
ancillary platforms right so like reddit
is it huge in traditional marketing even
YouTube's not that big and I think a lot
of traditional marketing plans those are
much bigger in crypto like how do you
think about the intersection of a
company like eToro that does you know
literally sponsors I'll call it soccer
they call it football teams cabs and
then also like you have to deal with
these platforms that are more kind of
niche like what do you guys think about
there yeah so it's it's interesting
right like
reddit really was crypto Twitter before
crypto Twitter I think most people were
talking about it on reddit before they
you know were [ __ ] posting on on Twitter
all day that's where I discovered
Bitcoin for the first time but the flip
side of it is that now reddit for a
large percentage of the content on there
has actually been game of Fayed by
marketers so most of the stuff that does
hit the front page or hits your timeline
is something that someone more than
likely manipulated to get there in one
way or another and I'm not saying all of
the content is but a good chunk of it is
there ad platform is improving over time
but you know it's notoriously
inefficient so whether that's from a
targeting standpoint or just performance
overall it's always at least been a
struggle for me and I think a lot of
people would agree with that skirt
school want to know who has the best URL
crypto com
that's right crypto calm their crypto
platform with one goal mother mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them Tom sent you and thank me
later one more word from our sponsor
blocked by their new interest account
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
ether at block 5 and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent a py which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump
- sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today so now it's a good
time disclosure I'm an investor in
reddit through an STV we did good but
with YouTube for example you know it's
similar to Twitter in the way that there
are some huge crypto influencer like
doesn't almost doesn't feel like the
right word for the people on YouTube
like people like Luke Martin who are
just churning out all this really
high-end content all the time and there
are people like learning how to do their
entire careers based on watching videos
of him every day right it is one of the
fastest growing platforms in marketing
in general and I think people have
started noticing how YouTube has really
invested in their ad placements they're
blowing and blowing it up you can do
Google Shopping ads through YouTube
placements now they have banner ads on
top of their actual like video ad
placements the pre rolls and the mid
rolls and everything so whether you're a
crypto company or an e-commerce brand or
whatever spending money through either
through retargeting or even acquisition
on YouTube is has to be part of your
your mix yeah
what is the not nutty torus I'm gonna
get into the confidential information
but just in your mind like what is the
difference between traditional marketing
and these social platforms from a cost
of acquisition standpoint yeah is it a
material you know like like a magnitude
difference is it actually not as big of
a difference as people think just like
how do you think about I have X dollars
to spend I need to be as efficient as
possible
is it true that the online platforms
were that much more efficient or is it
really the case depending on what I'm
trying to accomplish and what the
channel that uses yeah I mean customer
acquisition costs are actually not that
much different when you're sort of
setting your flagpole based on what you
know traditional financial firms are
looking at or reported to be looking at
it's not that that far off which is
actually really really encouraging
considering the size of the crypto
ecosystem versus the addressable market
of like sofa or wealthfront for example
for sure I want to play a game I didn't
tell you you're gonna play this game
okay let's do this I want to go through
and see one for one to name every person
we could think of on Twitter first one
to not be able to name somebody loses to
not be able to name something yeah so
okay throw out a name I throw out a name
and we'll see who who has to give up
first all right they have to be somebody
who there's three criteria yeah they
have to be somebody who's into Bitcoin
crypto etc yeah they have to be
regularly engaged yeah right and they
have to have some element of being a
smartass a troll or a [ __ ] poster oh man
that's a lot of pressure all right you
go first
all right I got a shout out my buddy
Cody is fun all right I'm gonna go with
my guy Peter McCormick the troll of all
troll how's my next one how about we go
with Peter Schiff on this next time all
right
I'm gonna go with rhythm trader
ohm in response to every one of my
tweets rate and and rides off into the
virality which I appreciate
yeah shut up Marty been already been our
I'll go with his counterpart Matt O'Dell
who else we got here Tom Shaughnessy Tom
Shaughnessy okay I will go with Balaji
nice
who should I get let's go yoni Oh
yeah datura CEO all right well okay then
I'll go exact prints let's go Bryan
Armstrong on this one all right I will
go with I feel like we should call her
the queen of Wall Street at this point a
taint land long nice
let's go crypto Bobby crypto Bobby I
will go with Tom Oh Shawn or Jimbo
Shaughnessy almost got me
shoutout Jim o Shaughnessy who was one
of the first three guests ever on
off-the-chain and came on and said at
least 50 times I don't know let's do
crypto Randy crypto Randy I will go with
Jill Carlson and I'll throw in the next
one and melt them yeah what what grinds
my gears like this podcast go ahead
let's do oh I just had it I lost it
it's over on the spot it's almost right
literally uh oh man he really lost it Oh
Luke Martin is what I was gonna say it's
over all right we kind of got for a long
time it really could um the reason I
wanted to do that is if you look at all
of those people they all have completely
different roles in an ecosystem totally
and it's like the WWF and I talked about
this on the podcast before but like
there's the heroes
there's the villains there's like the
tag team partner there's right like you
get all this stuff and it's
entertainment I did end of the day like
when you get on Twitter yes there is
like information and you're learning and
education and all that but it's
entertainment like there are people
dunking on each other there are people
trolling each other there are people who
have like the long-standing feuds there
are the people who are like overly nice
to each other and like how does that
company play into that see you thought I
was joking around okay I was like well
that was a long way to get to that
question with the game but that's you
know Twitter feuds are a funny thing
right like some of those are a little
bit manufactured for the sake
of impressions and some of those become
real-life beefs and I think the ones
that are real-life beefs are things that
are coming largely from a good place
right like people have philosophical
differences on the role of certain parts
of crypto and blockchain tech that
really hit home for these people like
some people are really into lightning
Network and some people really like to
troll lightning network people
same with XRP and vice versa right so
when you're a brand in an ecosystem
where this is likely to happen you
typically try to stay out of it
but you know sometimes it's good when
there are trolls spending a bunch of
time talking about you because sometimes
that's a really interesting way to farm
new farmer followers on your brand and
eventually they convert into new
customers
is there one troll that picks fights
with people that you would say has done
it well like it like I said in a
positive thing and you can you can opt
out I'll give you an escape route if you
don't want to answer but I'm just
wondering like from a and not like
somebody picks fights necessary but just
have trolls really well and it's worked
out so he is not a troll there's a great
human being
but Peter McCormack's beefs are actually
noteworthy for a number of reasons I
mean like the the whole lawsuit thing
that's going on this is like an
interesting thing that we should
probably be talking about like someone's
trying to claim a role of being the
inventor of Bitcoin and you know one
could argue that maybe that person
should be able to prove it and you know
so that person is also suing other
people for saying the contrary so maybe
this is something that we should be
paying attention to I mean there there's
I love that you stay you answer with
Peter McCoy it's so I'm gonna go with
that one all right that's fair what uh
what's the one thing that you believe in
marketing and crypto that you think most
people don't understand or agree
with but you would want them to learn
about so basically what's the secrets
yeah though honestly with marketing and
crypto it's you got to think of it as a
long game right like in a lot of ways
certain key like boilerplate direct
response marketing things are not as
effective as one would think so if
someone's coming from a direct response
to digital agency and is like let's put
all this crazy amount of money into
Adwords well if you're a small company
with lean budgets that might not be the
best way to do it especially if you're a
new company with not a lot of brand
recognition you should probably invest
in something that's just gonna get as
many eyeballs from your market segment
on your brand as possible and then rely
on your company being noteworthy enough
to you know acquire the press mentions
which is really you know a really big
part of marketing and cryptos being able
to be noteworthy there sure and then
what um what do you see are the biggest
mistakes that people make in that vein
right so there's definitely the people
who come from trishal marketing who
maybe don't understand the nuances of
crypto but yeah what are some of the
mistakes you see teams making yeah I
think the people that are trying to
monetize memes right so I can't remember
who it was but someone tried to
trademark like the stacking SATs thing a
while back and I get it because the
claim was that they were trying to like
protect it for the community and that's
what they said when they did it to and
when they presented it but there were a
lot of people that took exception to
that so it you know the brands aren't
doing that to like screw you over
they are going into it with good
intentions in mind but sometimes it's
hard to anticipate what the water
community is gonna try to go for yeah
and there was another way to stack
stacking SATs was one and there was
another thing somebody try wait who's
coinbase tried to like Hodel or
something like that was that what it was
there was some other term that people
tried to trademark and again they were
saying hey look we're not using an
offensive manner yeah
it's more defensive yet still people not
uh not thrilled about it it's a tough
spot well we see eat or oh in the future
get into similar things like they're
doing international to talk about stocks
are coming at some point yeah what can
you say about like other things you guys
are either thinking about or other
things that you personally would like to
see you guys get into anything you could
talk about there yeah I think I mean I
can't get into too many details because
we want it to be a surprise all right
there's a PR person staring at me when I
ask this question it's like it's like
being under the gun but I asked it
anyways so what I can say is that we're
just trying to offer products that
people want to use and the exchange game
really is about being sticky so that
like you were alluding to a little bit
earlier like retention is a big part of
that so when you're thinking about how
to retain people what do they want to
see what are they what exchanges are
they likely using mostly and what are
the limitations of those platforms we
think that we already have a lot of
really great value propositions that can
be compete or beat what other people are
offering but being able to not only
surpass what other competitors are doing
but also be comparable with like
incumbents in the traditional financial
tools world that's really important so
you see you know Robin Hood and all
these companies trying to become
non-bank lenders in the same way that's
so Phi's been doing it because they're
trying to acquire more customers before
making that attempt to go public or
whatever right so it's about being
sticky and you know listening to your
customer base got it before I wrap up I
always ask rapid-fire set of questions
yeah what's the most important company
in crypto other than eToro
or blocked by other than eToro and block
Phi I really love the block the block
III that's a controversial topic I think
that those guys do a really good job of
contextualizing everything from big to
small stories in the space that help you
know
people that are even knew to crypto at
least understand what's going on right
it's really easy to get lost in a lot of
the other publications and I think that
you know the people over there are great
and they do a really good job at what
they do what's the one regulation you
would change or improve if you could hmm
I'm not sure I got head shaking in my
mom let's go you know I'm not too
focused on pending legislation when it
comes to crypto okay I'm more focused on
making crypto approachable for the
average consumer right we put a lot of
thought into the balance of are we
talking only to crypto people are we
trying to convert what we call pre
coiners into the ecosystem and I think
that there are a lot of existing options
for people that are really deep into
crypto they live and breathe it but
getting my dad into it that's a whole
challenge that I don't think anyone in
the ecosystem has really cracked really
so we're investing quite a bit and
figuring out how to do that for those
that don't realize what he just did he
didn't answer the question but that's
fine
what's the most controversial thought
you have in crypto I think that that we
should be open to the idea of
governments digitizing fiat currencies
because I think that although a lot of
people hate the idea of it very
legitimately because there's serious
privacy concerns that go along with that
it becomes significantly easier to you
know lock people out of the economy you
know follow all the trip
payments people are doing but the way
that I think about it is when you
introduce on that scale and this is you
know this goes into Libra a little bit
as well when you're introducing people
at the scale of like 360 million people
all at once or you know a couple billion
people overseas into the crypto
ecosystem and the government is finding
a way whether you think that's efficient
or not finding a way to make that an
easy an easy enough process that people
can just opt-in really simply that is
only from that perspective a good thing
for crypto largely yeah it's uh
I always just look at it as what more
people have digital wallets yeah and if
more people of digital wallets they have
choice exactly and they can use whatever
they want yeah and it's our job to
educate them on why totally like Bitcoin
is better than digital fiat yeah but
digital fiat will accelerate digital
wallet adoption absolutely like they're
I think one of the biggest gaps and to
onboarding into crypto is actually the
terminology like my dad conceptually can
understand what a wallet is but trying
to explain seed phrases and how
important they are to like save and the
fact that there's no one to call if he
loses them like his email password that
he loses what you get to do it's a big
deal exactly so that's why even though
it's a little bit controversial
centralized
options are really important for what I
consider the average person yeah and and
again it's you need both right you know
decentralized personal freedom base yeah
you know kind of Bitcoin etho based
options and then you also need
decentralized version because there's
just some people aren't going to buy
into or get comfortable with the other
one exactly what's the most important
book you've ever read I really love this
is marketing by Seth Godin probably read
it two and a half times and every time I
mean that's not a lot but
I'm presenting it as if it's my like
Bible here but every time I read it
there's like a new nugget and the reason
I say two and a half is because I'm
constantly going back to like a page
that I marked yeah because there's
always something that I'm extracting
from that what uh what's another book
other than a marketing book see people
come in here and they're all prepared
answer questions and then I just throw a
loop now what's the second most
important hmm maybe this is uh this
doesn't reflect well on me but I spend a
lot of time reading newsletters and like
money stuff for example Matt Levine yeah
every get Matt in here yo you have to do
that absolutely money stuff you know he
is an amazingly talented writer in the
way that he can turn a story that you
are you you're assuming is gonna go one
way into something else he always ties
an implication of one story into
something else that's going on and it
really just broadens the way that I
think about how you know one industry
affects another or how there's always
something going on behind the scenes in
a macro sense that's affecting all these
sorts of businesses in ways that we
wouldn't you know the layman wouldn't
anticipate for sure
aliens real or not I think probably real
why just statistically oh no no no come
on why you have never come to earth no I
don't think that's true why not I mean I
think statistically I'm open to the idea
I would I would not be like a naysayer
if there was like some sort of concrete
proof I'm like all about these New York
Times articles that keep coming out
twice a year New York Times like this is
it you know like alien here CT recom
this is like legit media is saying hey
this might be real yeah but I'm like you
know my life is not about that so I just
don't spend too much time on it but I
think for sure there's life somewhere I
I don't know when this is gonna get
posted so I think this is gonna come out
before
the alien interview but I'm interviewing
a guy tomorrow who he claims that 780
thousand years ago there was a I get
this Curt I might get this wrong but
basically an alien tech no signature
extraterrestrial post biological
artificial intelligence spacecraft that
blew up and that's where all these
materials and people are showing up that
have different physical property like
physics of in quantum of properties
that's where that material came from is
from the seven hundred eighty thousand
years ago a alien spacecraft with all
those characteristics blew up and
crashed in earth but couldn't it have
just been like asteroids hitting the
earth that contain those properties for
sure maybe but maybe the asteroid had
the aliens on it who knows I tend to
think that the simpler explanation is
probably what happens I got intrigued
just because I want to know what an
extraterrestrial whose biological
artificial intelligent alien aircraft in
flight all right well one question you
have for me to finish up what do you
think the next stage in crypto is so
when you think about the focus over the
last year and a half on making products
that are approachable by consumers and
usable with a good use UX what is the
next step now that we have good UX is
what's what's the next step
there's three milestones that I'm
waiting for one is a sovereign nation
acquiring Bitcoin and putting it in
their national reserves and I think that
you will see a bonanza like you think
you've seen a chart go bend backwards
like that thing will explode that's one
and we kind of saw that this week with
China saying that they were going all-in
on blockchain and it was a Bitcoin yeah
but they definitely directionally are
now becoming more public about hey this
is serious this is important we're gonna
make it a national initiative the second
thing I think is today we're coming out
like 1% of the world's population about
70 million people I think that when we
get
to 10% so like an order of magnitude
from here I think a lot of people I
think that's a yes 700 million people if
you think about that that's like really
breaking the threshold of like true
global adoption right but it's still you
have 90 percent to go from there we have
to get everyone so it's not like an
impossible number but it's also like so
you go from 70 into 700 like you got a
you know 10x right and what an indicator
would you use to know that like some
people like to look at the amount of
wallets that are being opened but you
know everyone has like 10 if you have
generated over time right so what are
you looking for I don't think it's one
metric Rene I think it's a whole host of
different things and then I think what
you probably can do if you really wanted
one metric is you could take that wallet
you try to figure out what's the average
number of walls somebody has so I can
cut it back into it or you can look at
the exchanges and you can probably like
you shop laid out how quickly they're
acquiring users right and then if a new
user comes into the ecosystem how many
exchange accounts do they set up is it
probably one and that for some period of
time it's 2 3 whatever it uh and then
what you can do is kind of like do some
math and say ok this is what we kind of
think it is but part of the beauty is
we'll never know yeah right yeah
absolutely and then the third one is I
think a sovereign nation not only puts
it in the reserves they adopt Bitcoin as
the goal as the national currency how
far away away from that 10 years old
less or less oh yeah Wow I think that
there's some countries that are really
really big trouble
yeah and I think somebody's gonna throw
a Hail Mary Yeah right like think about
iPhones 12 years old mm-hmm not really
that long right yeah feels like forever
it really does like feels like I like
grew up with this thing in my hand yeah
right yeah should I got first cell phone
when I was in high school right like it
wasn't a smart phone either rez yeah no
I actually think did you ever have one
of the sidekicks we didn't have them and
pull it out and you have the keyboard we
didn't have them in
man I didn't get once I was in college
but I wanted one so bad but like if you
think that right I post 12 years old if
you look at you know today yet bitcoin
is 11 right actually turns 11 on the
October 31st the white paper but like
I'll buy into the idea that in the first
20 years since the white paper gets
released one country decides and it
could be some you know nonsense small
like Hail Mary type situation or it
might not be like it may be some real
yeah you know established country but
like to me that is the the three
milestones right is you've got to get
somebody putting in the national reserve
and then you got to get it to 10 percent
global population and then you got to
get a contrary to accept it or to
identify it with it as its national
currency and then like hyper bitcoin
ization is a foregone conclusion at that
point right you know trace Meyer and
every other Yahoo's that you know from
early days of Bitcoin are all vindicated
yeah it's so far so good for them all of
them but I think that that's like when
it's gonna be pretty indisputable like
this is real cool you agree I do what 10
years or less than a country oh no so I
don't know I think that's a debatable
topic I mean what in your mind what is
like the impetus that they switch from
their Fiat to Bitcoin as they're like
national currency failing of the state
failing of the currency of the currency
yeah like their currency fails they're
like [ __ ] what do we do we keep trying
to starve another one yeah right yeah
we're like oh let's just use this one
okay we don't control over but neither
does anybody else
I think that we have to see a
stabilization of the price before we get
to that point it is stable how stable
well if you price goods in Bitcoin its
new that's true bitcoins always one
Bitcoin yeah I mean it's like dollars
right like technically the dollar
continues to lose value every year but
$1 $1 and it just costs more dollars to
buy that yeah asset and like I get some
like that analogy or whatever but at the
same time like that's the same way that
Fiat works right now is if the problem
is that what you're trying to buy you're
using one currency to buy something
priced in another currency if you price
everything in that currency hmm then you
don't have the clinical volatility
because you're just simply buying things
that are priced in the same currency
that you hold mm-hmm now it would be a
big you know kind of mental switch for
an entire country to do that but I think
that from a top-down in some countries
if the government said this is the new
national currency yeah like sure I just
wanna get paid man right I got so I
provide my family right I just live a
good life like the people aren't really
that complicated when you think of the
incentive system and then at what point
do we switch to Satoshi Cesare like main
unit well I think that's what would
happen whenever you know whenever you
switch the national currency right is
basically think most things would get
priced in satoshis just given that at
that point you know hit in the next ten
years it's like you know I don't think
bitcoins $8,500 right right yeah
what it is who knows but you know even
today at $8,500 you want to buy a pack
of gum like it's not gonna be you know
hey you owe me you know one ten
thousandth of a Bitcoin yeah it's
definitely be priced in institutions
right so I don't know all right thanks
for coming to do this sorry that I had
to embarrass the the PR completely
that's my new rules that people bring PR
folks they're getting embarrassed but I
getting the thumbs up from this that
means that it did we didn't violate any
rules and where can people go find out
more about eToro you can head to eToro
comm slash pop slash pumped find out
more go in fund your account complete a
trade and pretty soon you'll be able to
copy other people awesome in and where
can they find you you find me on twitter
at Brad Michaelson that's a very
original name I know I thought really
hard about it
I'm a thanks so much we'll do it again
Thanks hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us to take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain